[RUBIK'S CUBE TURNING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey Numberphile, my name is
Lucas and I'm a speed cuber.
So I'm going to solve this
Rubik's Cube for you.
- I'm Adam and I'm gonna
solve the Rubik's Cube.
- That was about 9.6 seconds.
Although we've got a
little bit left.
- And then you're gonna time
it with this program.
- Hi.
This my Rubik's Cube, solving
it for Numberphile.
Nicholas.
- Hi, my name is Ethan Fenlan
and I'm a big fan of Brady
Haran's videos.
- I love Numberphile.
It's great.
And I saw the first--
- --which include Numberphile
and Sixty Symbols.
- Periodic Videos,
Numberphile.
- Hi Numberphile.
This is me.
- a lot of really cool science
channels, asked for videos of
people, fans of him, solving
Rubik's Cubes.
- Today, Rubik's Cubes.
Why?
Because Numberphile
asked for it.
- And he was looking for someone
to solve a Rubik's
Cube.
- Hi, my name is Glen.
And this is my contribution
to [INAUDIBLE]
Numberphile video, which is
about Rubik's Cubes, I guess.
- OK, I actually got
a pretty easy case.
- Hey, this is a video prop.
Ready?
- Hello YouTube and
hello Brady.
This is my Rubik's Cube
attempt to solve.
- Hey Numberphile, I'm Owen.
I'm 10 years old and I'm going
to be solving this complete
mess in front of me.
- Hello Brady.
You want it solved,
so here's mine.
- Here we have a Rubik's Cube.
- Well, there you go Brady.
Hope that's alright for you.
- A quick video for
Numberphile.
- Hello Brady, this is
Mathmetical Brony here, and I
hope I'm not to late, but I want
to submit a video of me
solving my Rubik's Cube.
- What's up Numberphile?
You wanted a Rubik's Cube
solved, so here you go.
- Usually I tend to hold it a
bit lower, but in this case,
I'm just going to try to have it
on camera the entire time.
- One of the YouTube channels I
follow, Numberphile, the guy
behind that, Brady, was asking
for videos of people solving
Rubik's Cubes.
And I'm sure I've mentioned it
before, but I can solve one.
Very slowly.
- OK, and this took 24
seconds, point 76.
And as you can see, the
cube is solved.
[RUBIK'S CUBE TURNING]
- Oh, I beat my record.
- Well, maybe.
46.
- Lock up.
[RUBIK'S CUBE TURNING]
-No.
- Well, there you go.
[RUBIK'S CUBE TURNING]
- That's it.
Solved the Rubik's Cube.
- And now it's all solved.
So--
ah--
- Hey guys, this is just gonna
be a video of me solving the
Rubik's Cube for the Numberphile
channel.
- In minutes.
Hey, we did it.
There's my best actually.
Two minutes, 40 seconds.
Look at that.
- Hello, it's Dan.
And this is me solving the
Rubik's Cube for Periodic
Videos and Numberphile.
- One time I was solving it-
- Hey Brady, my name's Albert.
I saw that you were taking--
[RUBIK'S CUBE TURNING]
- And I got a time
of 11.47 seconds.
- Yes!
120, a new record.
- So Brady, I hope that
helps, and everyone
else, thanks for watching.
- And there we go.
Brady, this is your solved
Rubik's Cube.
All the best, and I hope
you'll be educating and
entertaining us for the
coming decades.
Have a good one.
And I hope
this helps - Done.
I guess the only challenge
left is this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]